normalement faire un pas de la traction
famille c'est sympa une balle et cinq
qui tirent la tête là se noue le moral
lié aux occupants 14 ans il vole jogi
löw va dedans moi je faisais pipi ça
fait deux offres ont fait la queue pour
toi alors notre temps tu te rends tu es
tu voles vote dans lé bien ma chérie on
va laisser partir son petit tour de
bateau il ya des moments où on aimerait
bien changer de famille mais faut faire
attention à ce qu'on souhaite vous vous
rendez pas compte en fait on a transféré
nos esprits dans le corps de quelqu'un
d'autre
c'est l'hécatombe
à l'hôpital on va considère comme des
cobayes sur une table en inox et fait 6
passes à vos partenaires et malade avant
tout un an j'ai mal au zizi il est sous
gonflés
y avait plus qu'à se cacher et attendre
que ça passe
mais non c'est devenu encore plus
compliqué sérieux c'est dans le corps de
papa maintenant c'est qu'il n'y a pas
mieux
oui c'est ça j'en suis vieille et moche
barbus mais quand je termine aussi avec
toute cette wii fit et bozon dagogo faut
pas s'étonner
il ya quand même quelques son style ph
plan mais quand je dis compliqué mais
bon nous disent ah bah moi enfin trois
mois non toi moi eh ouais je te rappelle
je t'explique premier
[Musique]
elle fumait elle avait des seringues sur
edit ah non ça c'est normal ça mérite un
chemin bien c'est pour vous sa mère
assise
allez on y va un peu plus de son corps
on fait deux ans qu'ils ne touchent plus
tu croyais kouadja interne
là nous
[Musique]